tu veux bien m'aider s'il te plait je
voulais que je t'aide pour faire quoi
était le bébé écureuil à remonter dans
son nickel bébé écureuil et ils tombent
tous les jours réglé comme une horloge
tu veux bien prendre cette corde et me
la passer autour de la taille
voilà premiers mois de ne pas lâcher
je vais présenter aux autres
pensionnaires nous sommes ce qu'on
appelle communément des êtres
particuliers
vous connaissez les genoux
les voix c'est clair
milliards de la balle là bien sûr c'est
nul à aller et lu ting
fish avant de s'occuper de parole et
petite ombre une de voici me voilà
c'est bon
tchèque
je suis ce que je peux pour le retarder
est ce que tu te rends compte que tu
vises comme un pied et avec cet engin
trouvez-moi à l'entrée d'avant crise
un autre tu devras reprendre des
respirations et alors
tout sera dit
ce sera la mort pour tes amitiés qui
vise pérégrine la vie éternelle pour moi
un parti
pour toi nous sommes ce qu'on appelle
communément des êtres particuliers
jeunes à vous avez 50 et une seconde de
retard
excusez moi miss perry green qu'une
carotte faut-il pour leur part pour
s'asseoir une selle les gens comme nous
sont persécutés depuis la nuit des temps
c'est pour cela que nous vivons dans des
endroits comme celui-ci j'appartiens à
une certaine catégorie les embrouilles
oui je sais les gens qui se transforment
en oiseaux
vous avez raison c'est exact mais ça ne
sert pas à grand chose
le principal talent du nombre une et la
manipulation temporelle nous choisissons
un endroit sûr et un jour tranquille et
nous créons une boucle je comprends pas
une boucle temporelle permet de
sauvegarder les dernières 24 si on
renouvelle la boucle on peut de nouveau
vivre ces 24 si on recommence chaque
jour ces 24 heures dur pour l'éternité
et on y résident à jamais à l'abri du
monde extérieur
toutes les ombres une s'engage à créer
et diriger un établissement tel que
celui ci
un foyer pour enfants particulier
suis moi c'est là que je vais quand j'ai
envie d'être seule
il
vous
quant au score
comment comment tu as fait pour l'air
c'est ça ma particularité si tu veux que
je te mens tu le reste il faut me
promettre de pâtes enfuir
avec pile à l'heure miss pérégrine soyez
les bienvenus
il est invisible absolument
pour dire les choses simplement nous
sommes 10 en particulier vous ne mangez
pas clair elle est gênée à cause de jake
faux pas
comme nos dons ne sont pas adaptés au
monde extérieur
nous vivions dans des lieux tels que
celui-ci
on ne risque pas de notre oreille
tchèque vient joie de voir j'ai su que
vous étiez des nôtres dès que vous êtes
mais il est temps que vous découvriez de
quoi vous êtes capables mais moi je suis
un garçon ordinaire non au contraire ton
destin est de nous protéger
promettez moi une chose fait il serait
c'est promis